my name is Thomas NIR I'm a professor
and chair of ecology and
here at Yale University I also serve as
the Bingham oceanographic curator in the
Yale Peabody Museum of Natural History
and I'm a member of the Terry
lectureship committee the Dwight H Terry
lectureship was established in 1905 by a
gift from Dwight Harrington Terry of
Bridgeport Connecticut to endow a series
of lectures on religion and its
application to human welfare in the
light of scientific knowledge and
philosophical insights the lectures are
published in book form by Yale
University Press previous Terry lectures
lecturers have included Carl Jung
Margaret Mead Rebecca West Peter Singer
and Terry Eagleton and along with this
illustrious and esteemed set of Terry
lecturers it's my privilege to introduce
dr. Thomas Lovejoy he'll be giving a
series of three lectures for the 2018
Terry lecture Shep
for the past 30 years dr. Lovejoy has
worked on the interaction between
climate change and biodiversity through
his work in science and conservation
pilot policy he is widely known as the
godfather of biodiversity dr. Lovejoy
received his Bachelor of Science and
doctorate as a graduate student working
with the legendary evylyn Hutchinson in
biology from Yale University starting in
the 1970s he helped bring attention to
the issue of tropical deforestation and
in 1980 published the first estimate of
global extinction rates and coined the
term biological diversity with two
co-edit books co-edited books published
in 1992 in 2005 he is credited with
founding the field of climate change
biology Lovejoy has served on science
and environmental councils under the
Reagan Bush and Clinton administration's
and was also the world bank's chief
biodiversity advisor and lead
specialists for the environment Latin
America and the Caribbean in March of
2010 he was elected University professor
at George Mason University
he previously previously held the
biodiversity chair at the Heinz Center a
center for science economics in the
environment and was a president of that
organization from 2002 to 2008 what
particularly resonates with me is a
quote from a right lecture that dr.
Lovejoy delivered in 2002 Lovejoy said
is nothing short of scandalous that we
probably know only one only know one of
every ten species on earth let alone
where they are or various aspects of
their biology this quote to me
encapsulates the vast lacunae in the
knowledge of biodiversity that continues
to motivate scientists to take on the
call to discover describe and help
conserve without further ado dr. Lovejoy
[Applause]
well thank you very much for when you
turn this on thank you very much for the
opportunity to be here once again at
Yale in this really wonderful auditorium
and share some thoughts with you about
where we are in our relationship to the
biological world and how it might
improve so
in late August 1962 I flew to Cairo on a
year off between junior and senior year
to be part of the Yale Peabody Museum
prehistoric Nubia expedition the high
dam at s1 was under construction and
experts were trying to figure out how
Abu Simbel could be moved to a new
location above the future Lake Nasser
the Yale expedition was to look for
prehistoric artifacts I was added to do
Natural History collecting on the
premise the unfulfilled premise that
some biological remains might be found
associated with the artifacts but of
course it was also worthwhile on its own
our partner for that was the medical
zoology department of the u.s. Navy
medical research unit number three
nemrut 3 a leader in epidemiological
research in that corner of the world for
decades within about three days I was in
an am rude Jeep Caravan headed north on
the highway to Alexandria learning to
count in Arabic from the kilometer signs
along the road at Alexandria the caravan
turned left and headed into the western
desert our mission was to collect
mammals desert mammals which meant
collecting at night might we even see
cheetah which were once known in that
part of the world mammal collecting in
the desert is a nocturnal exercise so we
would need better when God's by
nightfall
we found them but before we could go on
the hunt we engaged in the millennium
old exercise a rug was spread out on the
sand and tea was made
there is not a drop of moisture in the
air so the night sky was brilliant with
stars to a degree one thought one could
even read by the pale blue light that
they cast looking up at that panoply of
stars one could understand why three of
the world's great religions started in
that part of the world
it automatically engenders wonder and
just at that moment I saw one of the
very first satellites pass overhead and
I realized for the first time that what
the American poet EE Cummings had called
the world of the born and the world of
the made were rushing apart and of
course they have been rushing apart
exponentially ever since it is not the
intent of these lectures to dwell on or
wallow in the grim statistics of
biodiversity loss or species extinction
let us simply represent this by noting
that humans and our mammalian livestock
now represent 80% of all mammalian
biomass and that 60% of terrestrial
large carnivore species and large
herbivores species are threatened with
extinction rather the intent is to
understand how and why we have gotten to
this point of assaulting the living
planet when it is essential to us in so
many ways and to explore ways to redress
this senseless imbalance
it is useful background to understand
how this planet became habitable for
humans and other forms of life it
certainly was not so at the outset
the atmosphere was only 2% oxygen and
the only forms of life were the
blue-green bacteria which recall
blue-green algae when I was an
undergraduate the blue-green bacteria
which survived but certainly in no sense
dominate today they were
photosynthesizers
and initially their oxygen interacted
with iron in the oceans leading to the
iron deficient ocean chemistry we have
today
once that iron in the oceans was
exhausted oxygen began to accumulate in
the atmosphere to the point that higher
life forms including ourselves became
possible and at a certain point the
concentration reached a level at which
it enabled the creation of the ozone
layer which in turn made possible life
on land when it reached around 15%
combustion namely fire became possible
without which we would have likely
remained bipedal organisms with nothing
like the impact we have accrued to date
imagine Yale without Benjamin Silliman
z' demonstration of the value of oil or
without some of the fortunes based on it
current atmospheric oxygen
concentrations are around 20% there
would be none of the astonishing variety
of life on Earth for us to understand
and explore without the transformative
oxygenation by the blue-green bacteria
it is also notable that for those
organisms oxygen was actually a toxic
waste substance and they filled up the
atmosphere with it to the point that
they made themselves marginal
it sounds familiar part of the
environmental challenge is that the
existence is that the existence as a
peaceable kingdom is actually not
possible because everything in that
famous painting actually feeds on
something else so the challenge to start
with is very complex it is not whether
we affect the environment or not its but
rather how much and in which ways in
advances in technology of course make
the impacts more complex and more
powerful only values keeps that from
being a slippery slope
we have been hunter-gatherers from the
beginning driven by our chase for sodium
fat and sugar because those were
originally relatively scarce resources
and while particular instances remain
debated our impact on fauna has been
massive and close to ubiquitous on land
and in the sea the recent discovery of
marks of hunting tools on the bones of
an elephant bird in Madagascar about
eight thousand years before present is
just the most recent example even when
we shifted to agriculture and human
settlements enabled by a favorable and
stable climate which is exceptional we
have acted more often than not like a
fugitive species simply moving on after
exhausting a stock or exhausting the
land that is a strategy that works quite
well for most fugitive species when
numbers are small but for us
it has reached a density and intensity
that regeneration of favorable habitat
is insufficient in scale and rate and
that of course is why one of the three
conventions created at the time of the
Earth Summit in 1992 focuses on
desertification and restoring degraded
lands the list of extinctions ranging
from the Steller's sea cow discovered in
1741 on the pacific coast of north
america and extinct by 1768 and the dodo
in the 17th century in the indian ocean
has turned into an exponential curve the
endangered species lists from the
International Union of the Conservation
of Nature
lengthen almost daily and the causes
have been moving from selective to
systemic the greatest of which is
climate change and as we think about
this it is important to consider the
work of Ruth Patrick a special friend
and colleague of GE Volyn Hutchinson
here at Yale
Ruth worked for many years at the
Academy of Natural Sciences of
Philadelphia including through her
hundredth year and actually made it 205
and you know usually when you live that
long you don't get much of an obituary
Ruth got quite an extraordinary one in
the New York Times
Ruth story is a fascinating one for many
many perspectives but the relevant
aspect here is her 1949 paper on
Biological survey work in the Conestoga
River Basin of Pennsylvania and that is
the Conestoga
that's where the Conestoga wagons were
built for westward expansion ruth
concluded from this very massive and
intensive bit of fieldwork and that's
the team on the screen that the number
and kinds of species in a river or
stream where's the number and kinds of
species in a river or a stream reflected
not only the natural physics chemistry
geology and biology but also the impacts
of human activities in the watershed in
other words the biological diversity of
the watershed integrates all the impacts
on the ecosystem I'll show you an
example of some field studies in England
at experimental field station called Ron
I'm sted and here you're looking at the
number of species from 1856 on the right
to 1949 on the left and the stressor in
this particular case is applications of
different kinds and levels of fertilizer
over those years and basically it drove
the species diversity down from 49 to 3
the next slide shows what happened when
that stress was removed and the species
were able to return one by one because
the stress was no longer being applied
to those fields so I refer to this as
the Patric principle and it is in fact
the basis for the aquatic work of the
Environmental Protection Agency and
actually the vast majority of
environmental work worldwide whatever
the ecosystem or whether they actually
understand
where the principal came from to state
the obvious conserving biodiversity
requires addressing all environmental
problems in addition to those such as
hunting fishing forestry and the like
that must directly affect organisms one
can see the patrick principle in the
presentation of the planetary boundaries
and this is the very first version which
was I think 2009 and in it I believe the
the excursion beyond the green inner
safe historical zone of nitrogen is
probably about correct the number of
dead zones on in coastal waters around
the world has been doubling every decade
for four decades the climate change
excursion I think was underestimated and
Johan agrees with me and we've discussed
this because its effect on living
systems on biodiversity were not
included and of course biodiversity is
the biggest of them all even though I
think it's underestimated it's the
greatest because it is affected and
integrates the impacts of all the others
so the the planetary boundaries model
has its critics some pick at the details
and there are at least two more versions
since this one others don't like the
notion of boundaries yet what this does
I think really importantly is recognize
the conditions that nurtured the rise of
human civilization
and it is pretty obvious when you think
about it that way that it makes little
sense to exceed those boundaries far
better to direct human ingenuity to
creative ways of returning to and living
within those boundaries some don't like
the notion of tipping points as if
humanity somehow has a god-given right
to exceed any limit yet we know they
actually exist perhaps most notably
evident in this country in the prescient
advice of John Wesley Powell that
westward declines in rainfall gradients
implied the need for a different
approach to agriculture west of the
hundredth Meridian the result of course
of ignoring his council was the Dust
Bowl today for example we know of a
similar situation involving the
hydrological cycle of the amazon basin
where science allows us to actually see
the tipping point in advance which i
will touch on in the third lecture our
planet is filled with such systems and
possible tipping points many of which
currently are unknown when we recognize
them our tendency is to go right up to
the asymptote and then be surprised when
some other unanticipated factor pushes
the system beyond the carrying capacity
it would be the ultimate folly of course
to do this at the planetary scale it is
also clear we are currently seeing the
beginnings of but not the inevitability
of the sixth extinction in the history
of life on earth some of my academic
colleagues like to debate
whether it actually is at hand but in my
view that represents a distraction from
tackling the problem I mean like when
the oceans begin to wet begin to pull
away from the shore who doubts that a
tsunami will follow in 1976 I addressed
the topic of triage in analogy to the
world war one medical approach basically
dividing the wounded and the casualties
into three categories those who could
probably manage without much attention
those that could survive with attention
and those that it probably was a losing
effort to try and save and people had
started to sort of raise that question
about endangered species so I wrote this
article in the Bicentennial issue the
Smithsonian magazine and of course today
this kind of question has arisen again
which species should we try to save and
which not what to do when the endangered
species list grows and the budget does
not how to make such impossible choices
yet there is another choice which is of
course to correct the human trajectory
increase budgets and try much harder the
story of Noah in the Abrahamic religions
of Judaism Christianity and Islam
provides an interesting perspective all
animal species were invited on the ark
presumably plants as well although there
is no mention of that but more
importantly when the flood receded and
the animals were free to leave the ark
and return
God promised Noah and the animals and
the animals that it would not happen
again there was room for all and God to
send a rainbow to confirm the covenant
with Noah and the animals in my view
humanity should do no less it is also
important to remind ourselves that life
in all its splendor the best of our
knowledge is unique to our planet as
David coiin recently wrote in the
tangled tree life is a story that has
unfolded here only on a relatively small
sphere of rock in an inconspicuous
corner of one middling galaxy it is a
story that to the best of our knowledge
occurred just once it is very clear in
the recent papal encyclical laudato see
that the entirety of creation should be
valued
Pope Francis drawing on st. Francis of
Assisi and his love of animals speaks of
the need oops
sorry about that not quite ready for
that
well we can leave that
[Music]
well we're gonna skip to something that
was supposed to be a tiny bit later but
it's so this is a simulation
I think there's no question that the
passenger pigeon had the largest
population of any bird species on earth
but returning to the issue of laudato si
and st. Francis his love of animals Pope
Francis speaks of the need for care for
all species as part of what he calls our
common home for him as for Francis each
species has an intrinsic value as one of
God's creatures and as part of the
intricate ecosystems that are our home
less formally gerald durrell you once
because of this school got an honorary
degree from Yale for his books and for
his conservation work Jerry Durrell
referred to it as God's heart gallery so
one of the new roles of the new field of
religion in ecology is interpreting the
genesis passage on Dominion to suggest
that it was intended not to encourage
exploit exploitation but rather
something more akin to stewardship eco
theologians and ethicists here at Yale
and elsewhere are now reinterpreting
this in the light of such ideas and care
for creation this is why the joint
program between Yale School of Forestry
and environmental studies in the
Divinity School and the new Masters of
Arts
arts and religion at the Divinity
Divinity School are so important in
these discussions how we value species
as a matter of both principle and
practicality a moral and an aesthetic
imperative as well as a pragmatic act of
survival we need to develop a broader
basis for the valuing of nature and of
species by drawing on ecology ethics and
economics what we were engaging with is
what early Yale School of Forestry
graduate Leopold stated in his essay on
a monument to a pigeon
not just any pigeon of course but rather
the passenger pigeon the video of which
we've just video simulation of which
we've just seen and the last individual
of which Martha died September 1 1916 in
the Cincinnati Zoo Leopold wrote for one
species to mourn the death of another is
a new thing under the Sun we should
recall another Leopold II and reflection
if the land mechanism as a whole is good
then every part is good whether we
understand it or not to keep every cog
and wheel is the first precaution of
intelligent tinkering that is true
whether the part may be even if it seems
to our living limited understanding to
be redundant or unnecessary because we
simply do not understand the changing
significance of its role under natural
environmental variation even if some
unthinking person chooses to ridicule a
poor hapless arthropod species endemic
to the left eyebrow of dromedary camels
how that refers to disease organisms is
more of a puzzle and not entirely clear
yet we learned so much about the
complexity of biological systems as we
study them even out of ignorance some
somebody asks what good is it that is
usually more self commentary again
Leopold the last word of ignorance is
the person who says of an animal or
plant to which today of course we must
add the archaea what good is it
personally I find that akin to pointing
to a book unread on somebody's bookshelf
and asking what good is it
evylyn hutchinson here on the screen
called the father of modern ecology
pointed out that biological diversity is
essentially a vast living library for
the life sciences mostly unread and
having more valid value when reread in
the light of more recent biological
knowledge so more than half of us in
this hall simply would not be here but
for the serendipitous observations that
transform the life sciences namely
Edward Jenner's notice that milkmaids
with cow pox infections were immune to
smallpox leading to vaccination which
was named for the vaccinia virus which
in turn was derived from the latin for a
cow or ally or Alexander Fleming's
notice of the laboratory culture of
bacteria impeded by a Penicillium malt
that led to antibiotics these kinds of
discoveries are being made constantly
whether blood pressure drugs derived
from an understanding of how the
Bushmaster snake's venom works or the
Nova Scotia soil fungus capable of
blocking the mechanism used by attaboy
resistant bacteria or a peptide in the
blood of Komodo dragons with similar
properties this works and is because
each species represents they set a
unique set of solutions to a set of
biological problems with new solutions
arising daily this is not like a musty
old library of classics
rather new biological innovations are
occurring daily through continual
experimentation and natural selection
almost all societies value libraries
what might it take to extend that view
to the variety of life on Earth the
foregoing examples of course are
utilitarian in value as is the vast
array of services including climatic
stabilization generated by the organisms
that compose these ecosystems far from
putting a price on nature as some object
finding ways to recognize those values
is important however incomplete because
otherwise they are simply valued by many
people and by financial markets as zero
in lecture three we will describe how
restoring ecosystem services at a
planetary scale can help us
significantly address the human driven
emergency of climate change it is also
the case that an expanded ethical
awareness such as suggested by Aldo
Leopold in the land ethic can and should
be incorporated for the preservation of
ecosystems and species
he wrote the land ethic simply enlarges
the boundaries of the community to
include soils waters plants and animals
or collectively
the land in short a land ethic changes
the role of Homo sapiens from Conqueror
of the land community to plain member
and citizen of it it implies respect for
fellow members and also respect for the
community as such today's understanding
of environmental challenge which would
extend that to the oceans and to the
biosphere as a whole but here we are
like a troop of social primates so
intent on mutual grooming and cleverness
as to be oblivious to the yawning
environmental chasm of Iran making so
much so that the Oxford junior English
dictionary recently excised the
following words ACORN Bluebell nectar
Heron in favor of inserting blog
chatroom and voice mail in the meantime
we're continually inventing chemical
compounds new to nature and introducing
them heedlessly mostly unaware of their
deal dilatory ax sconce ik wences or
even more importantly and frightening ly
their interaction with one another
no wonder the vast array of summertime
nocturnal insects has then dramatically
in Europe and elsewhere Rachel Carson's
papers which were here at Yale in the
binary library are a testimony to the
power of her scientific studies her
press presence and her incredibly poetic
writing her 1962 book Silent Spring
of course alerted people to the dangers
of pesticides the consequence loss of
birds and insects and launched the
modern environmental movement and
parenthetically
I consider the three most important
books about environment and Noir
America in the 20th century to be sand
County Almanac Silent Spring and this
one often surprises people Roger Tory
Peterson's they feel God to the birds
because before it was published in
around 1933 there was no way to access
the world of nature through field God's
for anyone in addition those of us who
were aware seemed to have forgotten the
lessons of frugality that so marked the
generations that emerge from the
Depression and World War two from years
of sacrifice and rationing if the
records exist I expect that it would be
reflected in the menus of Yale dining
halls during that period and for some
time thereafter I can't imagine that
even in the rockefeller households they
had beef more than once a week
consumption seems to have become almost
and end in itself that we should be
paying attention to reducing our impact
on the living planet planet and it's
astonishing variety of living things
opined Dylan Ripley Yale ornithologist
Peabody Museum director and legendary
secretary of the Smithsonian every
biologist with a conscience should spend
some time on conservation that of course
was decades ago today he would embrace
the inclusive environmental agenda
clearly we need a redefinition of the
quality of life in which the more
fortunate of us need to reduce our
impact per-capita dramatically while
improving the environmental prospects
and well-being of the most of the more
impoverished of humanity present and
future there is an alternative to a
degraded planet
which if it if that degraded planet did
happen would constitute the greatest
environmental injustice of all time
because of its effects on the poor and
on future generations that would be a
planet in which degraded and poverty
so what we need instead would be a
planet in which degraded and
impoverished landscapes are restored
where Haiti once described by a
scientific colleague as the unthinkable
experiment no slightest would be allowed
to conduct is restored ecologically to
the benefit of all what is needed is a
new vision that embraces the grand
variety of life on Earth it would be a
vision in which all forms of life
flourish and human well-being becomes
more biologically based not a vision
that gives up too easily as to many
involved in the discussion about climate
change seem wont to do yes not exceeding
one and a half degrees may seem
impossible but it is the limit for a
function habitable functional planet for
Humanity and other forms of life as will
be discussed in lectures number three
different results and pathways emerge
when we think about these challenges and
when the question we ask is not if but
how I tell my students I believe it is
fundamentally wrong to eliminate or a
terminator 3.8 billion year long
evolution that each is a marvel in
itself and that living things are by
orders of magnitude a calculation
calculation never attempted the most
complex entities in the in the universe
they command off the eloquent and D
thinking Thomas berry stated to wantonly
destroy a living species is to silence
forever a divine voice that means all
species have a right to exist which is
completely congruent with Confucian
Taoist and Buddhist worldviews of
interdependence with indigenous life
ways with the intrinsic value of
creation and laudato si the creation and
the Abrahamic covenant with Noah there
should be room for all thank you very
much
[Applause]
we asked
how would you say that experience
spending time
violence adversity discovery description
how did that set you on your course or
okay and I talked my father into giving
me a trip to East Africa before I went
home I mortgaged every birthday
Christmas right now and I went to
basically British East Africa which
still existed for a few more months
Uganda Kenya and Tanzania and I became
besotted with East Africa my plan was to
do a PhD on montane forest birds in East
Africa and then my former freshman
advisor Philip Humphrey I told me if I
wrote a letter to somebody at the
Rockefeller Foundation I could spend the
summer with him in the Amazon and I
never looked back
right that's great there any other
questions for dr. Lovejoy yes thank you
so much really appreciate your talk you
mentioned some ambivalence about
disease-causing organisms I wonder if
you could expand on that and talk about
efforts to control mosquitoes that carry
malaria maybe make them extinct how
would you feel about that
so it becomes a really difficult sort of
conversation I mean there was there was
a time when we had almost completely
eradicated smallpox in the world and and
the idea was actually it would be smart
to save some of them somewhere so if
some new pox virus appeared we could
actually figure out how much of what we
knew about smallpox might be
transferable maybe today you could argue
if you had the whole genetic sequence of
smallpox you don't actually need to keep
the pathogen
but they're also really interesting
things that go on where you actually use
one pathogen bit of biology to work
against the impacts of another so it's
it's confusing on the other hand you
know if if one could introduce something
into the the exotic mosquitos in Hawaii
which basically you know I've been
driving the hawaiian honeycreepers
extinct because they transmit an avian
malaria that would came in from I think
chickens right there's some way to pull
that out of the system I'd be in favor
of it so it gets a little murky you know
when you get down to that level but when
you really think at the scale of what's
going on that's almost you know way
beyond the decimal point yes
yeah but why do that to ourselves right
yeah now that's my response yeah I mean
there's there should be a difference
between us and the blue-green bacteria
we know what we're doing to the
atmosphere
they didn't yes
reaching the scientific community or or
more broadly do you think it's been a
successful document in that sense and do
you think it the document itself is
sufficient for for informing this ethic
of ours so first of all it's very well
written it's extraordinarily well
written it's extremely sound
scientifically and one needs to remember
actually that Pope Francis has a
master's degree in science I can't
remember what it's in and that he
deliberately chose the name of Francis
you know you get to choose your own name
when you get to be Pope
so I think there's probably a segment of
the church which likes to ignore it you
know and Bill Reilly tells was a you
know goes to Mass on Sunday says he has
never heard it mentioned or even
environment mentioned so it really
depends a lot on the particular portion
of the church now there's a lot going on
right now
in terms of what the church might do
building up to a sign on around about
the Amazon so it's not like the Pope
plans to stop with just the document but
you know what we really need is you know
a revolutionary uptake of something like
that and we just have to keep plugging
at it and making the practical arguments
is same at the same time as we make the
ethical and the spiritual ones
there are no other questions just want
to invite everyone to join us for a
reception immediately following and
remind everyone that
[Applause]
[Music]